what's up guys so as you all already
know intro has become stagnant for the
past few years and only made incremental
upgrades to their chips each generation
because there unfortunately was no
competition however this year as AMD
released
Rison and started taking a significant
amount of market share endo started to
feel the heat and decided to release the
eighth generation of chips early and
this time they actually made a dramatic
upgrade to the chip what compared to
last generation however their process
still hasn't changed
and they have made yet another gree
iteration of the 40 nanometer process
and in Amite 40 nanometer plus plus in
their eye seven line they added two
cores for threads which effectively
decreased their core count by 40 to 50
percent this is definitely a significant
upgrade on paper but is that upgrade
able to relate to much superior
day-to-day performance well the extra to
course has increased her chips TDP to 95
Watts from 91 watts and force Intel to
lower their stock frequency by 500
megahertz from 4.2 Agora Hertz on the
intel i7 7700 k to 3.7 acres on the
intel i7 8700 kick the l3 cache has also
increased from 8 megabytes to call
megabytes however that PCIe lanes
remains at 16 lanes the stock frequency
decrease would make a noticeable
difference in applications that are
single thread intensive however the
Intel i7 8700 K is still able to be
overclocked quite a bit the 87 RK is
able to be overclocked to 5.0 meters for
most users gimmick efficient cooling and
if not that all ships reached the high
force with an average therefore this
ability puts it on par with the --into
7700 K which had similar overclocking
numbers I was able to overclock my until
I 780 700 K the 5.0 googors with the
coarser h100 I'd be to idle my
temperatures are in the low 30s and at
full load
my temperatures are in the mid 80s since
I clock speeds match now in theory the
performance of the intel i7 8700 decade
should be dramatically better than its
predecessor let's jump into some
benchmarks and find out on Cinebench r15
the 8700 k is a multi-threaded score of
1649 and a single thread score of 218 at
5.0 hertz a 7700 K at the same PI point
or Gertz has a multi thread score of one
thousand nine and a single thread score
of 210 the multi scored thread is very
different for the single thread
performance is near identical the multi
thread score is actually 50% higher on
the intel i7 8700 k so increase on paper
gus translate your synthetic increase
however is there a real-world
performance difference the answer is not
in daily tasks you are not going to see
a big performance increase if any we are
surfing the web are typing going on that
word document creating that next
presentation you're not even gonna see a
difference in good times or overall
snappiness asked for gaming this chip is
in fact the best gaming CPU available on
the market right now
but when you look at the difference in
FPS between the 8700 cake and the 7700 k
is just a few FPS it really doesn't make
a difference
I'm not being going to be going over any
gaming benchmarks be there plenty of
those on internet instead I prefer to
give you guys another opinion as a
result in gaming I would say that it
really does not make much of a
difference however in CPU intensive
workout applications it would definitely
make a difference for example your
premier Pro and After Effects renders
times would dramatically decreased and
your blender experience would be so much
smoother overall for a work type CPU
intensive application you would
experience quite a superior experience
with the intel i7 8700 k as a result who
should consider this cpu a cpu purchase
is more of a psychological aspect rather
than a logical one all of you guys have
craved the best gaming cpu available you
guys just go ahead and buy the cpu same
goes for everyone who wants the newest
Intel flagship product all of you guys
would never be satisfied with anything
else so you might as well just buy it
people who are on a tight budget and aim
to use your computer for work should
still get the CPU busy it really is
quite a nice upgrade for work-related
applications next all of these guys who
are gamers on tight budgets you guys
should not get the CPU instead you
actually get the in 8600 K or 7670 700 K
and use that money to upgrade your GPU
if it's not already maxed out and then
get SSD you don't already have one
none of those CPUs will actually
bottleneck the GPU and as a result you
guys should save your money and upgrade
your GPU first which will increase your
game experience much more than a CPU
upgrade especially considering how
overpriced the 8700 K is right now by
getting a 7700 K instead you guys should
save at least $200 that would be enough
to go up in GPU level or upgrade your
SSD storage which is both elevate your
gaming experience much more finally all
of you guys who can afford to 8700 K but
I prefer not to get it
it's not really that much better all the
gamers in that category
I don't recommend you guys get it great
it's really not a good value for how
much performance it gives you all the
people aiming to use their pcs for work
in that category you guys should get it
because it really is nice CPU as long a
budget really isn't a problem
overall this is the best CPU on the
market if you don't consider the
enthusiast lines of CPUs and it really
just perform to that name however there
are other things you got your upgrade
first if you guys are on a budget or
don't really want it for everyone else
who craves his CPU and wants the best
performance available this CPU is a
great Buy and all of you guys would be
very satisfied with your purchase well
guys that's all I have for you guys it's
time if you guys have interested in what
comes inside the box then make sure to
check out my unboxing and it by clicking
a link in the description below as
always if you guys like this video make
sure to give me that like if you guys
loved it and would like to see more
videos just like this and make sure to
subscribe and turn on that Bell
notification let me know what you guys
think about the CPU in the comments
below but until next time bye